public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dominique bussereau qui préside
l'association des départements de france
est l'invitée de l'épreuve de vérité
bonsoir bonsoir à vous et merci d'être
avec nous à ce rendez-vous de public
sénat avec la fp avec les échos et radio
classique je précise que vous êtes vous
même le président ait l'air de
charente-maritime et trois grandes
questions dominique bussereau vous
seront posées au cours de cette émission
d'abord en ce deuxième jour de
manifestations de la cgt
emmanuel macron at il raison de vouloir
tenir tête à la rue vous répondrez à
lucile bréau
si laurent wauquiez est élu président
des républicains pour en faire un parti
bien de droite
est-ce que vous claquer la porte eh bien
vous le dirai tout à l'heure à guillaume
daudin de l' agence france-presse
enfin le gouvernement at il est à la
grogne des élus locaux et notamment des
présidents de départements après la
toute dernière réassurance sur les
finances locales et réassurances
également sur les emplois aidés
et bien c'est mickaël szames s qui
abordera cette question tout à l'heure
une question clé on le sait bien sûr
pour les sénatoriales qui ont lieu
dimanche mais d'abord une toute première
question d'actualité
[Musique]
la fracture retentissante du front
national bien sûr celle du couple marine
le pen florian philippot est ce que vous
vous réjouissez que le front national
implose écouter les histoires internes
du front national c'est un long fleuve
qui n'a jamais été tranquille
le départ de bruno mégret la brouille
entre papa et sa fille le départ de la
nièce aujourd'hui le départ de florian
philippot voilà c'est toujours été une
histoire de famille une espèce de pme
politique qui connaît des développements
électoraux malheureusement trop
importante dans notre pays
voilà c'est leur affaire moi ça ne
m'intéresse pas à vous intéressé par ça
ne m'intéresse pas comment ça ça ne
m'intéresse pas parce que c'est les
histoires du front national et il n'ya
pas d'élections importantes à court
terme dans laquelle le front national
lors sera partie prenante vous parliez
des sénatoriales le front national y
joue un rôle l'infinitésimal les
européennes c'est en 2019 ya beaucoup de
choses qui vont se passer d'ici là dans
la vie politique française
on verra ce que sera le front national à
ce moment là en 2019 lorsqu'il y aura
une première grande élection nationale à
la proportionnelle ce qui pour le front
national est toujours un bon mode de
scrutin pour l'instant c'est vilenies
réciproque ses claquements de porte ses
affaires à la feydeau m'amuse parce que
j'aime bien fait dom et ne m'intéresse
pas sur le plan politique bon et qu'est
ce que vous avez comme message déjà
peut-être à transmettre aux électeurs du
front national tenait ce matin jean luc
mélenchon il a d'une certaine manière
tant que tendu la main il a dit
bienvenue les fâcher pas les fachos
savez c'est normal parce que quand on
regarde le vote des présidentielles et
législatives on voit la très grande
porosité qu'il y a eu entre l'électorat
de jean luc mélenchon ils font national
en particulier vu au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle
et on l'a vu aussi aux législatives en
particulier à à marseille voilà donc
c'est la sphère des extrêmes nous nous
représentons la famille de la droite et
du centre
classique et à côté de nous qui résume
parti socialiste si à côté de nous ce
qui se crée avec en marche c'est non
cette frange la de la société politique
que nous inscrivons et voilà on verra
bien ce que les extrêmes se prennent ou
semaine pas les uns les autres et ça
vous conforte dans l'idée de rejeter
vraiment toute alliance toute
perspective de rapprochement avec une
partie de cette boutade extraire écoutez
moi je suis entré en politique avec
giscard pour l'europe
pour une modération politique et pour
une politique libérale et sociale vous
voyez bien que ces trois valeurs sont
antinomiques des valeurs du front
national si tenté que ce soit des
valeurs et donc moi je sais que c'est
que n'ont pas les hommes et les femmes
ni les électeurs du front national mais
idées et le programme du front national
accord donc donc quand même florian
philippot il va sans doute se cherche un
avenir politique c'est pas 2 c'est pas
chez vous écoutez je le souhaite en tout
cas si c'était chez nous jeudi serait
plus d'accord et pour vous est-ce que
marine le pen ne sera la prochaine à
être évincé dans ce contexte que vous
avez résumé un peu à la feydeau saviez
les portes qui claquent allaman la
maîtresse ça sort le valet de chambre
fasse état c'est du théâtre
marine le pen a beaucoup déçu une partie
de son électorat le voit bien à une
étude très intéressante chez un de vos
confrères de la presse écrite la semaine
dernière sur la déception de l'électorat
front national vis-à-vis de marine le
pen en réalité de notre souci à nous
c'est d'agir pour que des hommes et des
femmes n'ait plus envie de voter front
national et en particulier c'est valable
dans la ruralité celle là dans le
périurbain
beaucoup d'hommes et de femmes qui se
sentent exclus vont voter pour le front
national donc notre boulot enlever les
électeurs fâchez pas fashion notre
boulot plus vite à monsieur mélenchon
oui ce sont déjà exclus moulin y aura
bien sûr des gens qui vont pas la fête
du village chez des gens qui ne parlent
pas leurs voisins qui n'ont comme
distraction que la visite du supermarché
le samedi après midi
ils connaissent même pas le prénom de la
caissière donc ces gens là il nous
appartient en particulier aux élus
locaux qui les connaissent qui vivent
avec eux deux près de les remettre dans
la république c'est ça le travail et ça
passe pas par une surenchère sur le plan
de l'ordre de la sécurité
c'est un travail de remise en forme
républicaine on en reparlera puisque
vous abordez la évidemment à la question
de l'avenir de lr on en rappeur là on en
parlera tout à l'heure mais tout de
suite c'est lucile bréau qui arrive
notre consoeur de radio classique
[Musique]
bonsoir lucile bonsoir michel bonsoir
messieurs qui seront sur votre question
ma question elle est assez simple elle
est d'actualité est ce que emmanuel
macron doit tenir face à la rue qui
manifestent aujourd'hui savez tous les
gouvernements doivent à la fois
dialoguer lorsqu'ils font des réformes
donc il certains gouvernements ont bien
fait d'autres y compris ceux auquel
j'appartenais peut-être n'ont pas
toujours bien fait qu'elle faut
dialoguer et après lorsqu'on propose
quelque chose qui va aller devant le
parlement
on sait bien que lorsqu'on prend tel ou
tel le décisions désagréables vis-à-vis
d'un corps social
les gens vont dans la rue après il faut
tenir je rappelle ce qui s'est passé en
95 avec la nage à ces termes à tous les
français disent c'est génial
bon et puis ils en ont marre ou quinze
jours de marche à pied parce qu'il ya
plus de métro plus de trains plus de thé
vert plus tramway et + bus et ils
implorent les députés de la majorité de
l'époque alain juppé de renoncer à ces
réformes
mais là vous lui demande emmanuel macron
de tenir bon de continuer dans ce cas
est élu sur les réformes
s'il ne fait pas les réformes il le
coupera le lien politique personnelle
moral un peu philosophique qu'il a eu
avec les français pendant cette élection
donc il est conduit naturellement à
tenir après il faut que ses ministres
soit capable de bien expliquer de bien
faire et que ces parlementaires qui pour
la plupart sont assez inexpérimentée
soit aussi capable de porter dans le
pays
le message des réformes du gouvernement
qu'ils soutiennent mais ils ont raison
les français descendent dans la rue
aujourd'hui quand vous les voyez
protesté se mobilise et vous estimez que
j'ai pas le sentiment qu'ils sont si
nombreux que cela je regardais chez
certains de vos confrères avant de venir
ici les images de la manifestation qui
est pas loin de vos studios entre la
gare montparnasse et la porte d'italie
et puis drain retrait par rapport à la
première manipulation mais ça semble
assez en retrait
ce qui veut dire que ce qui veut dire
que normalement la réforme des
ordonnances sur le travail devrait
passer et après il appartiendra au corps
social aux syndicats au patronat dans
les entreprises de le mettre en oeuvre
il faut tenir
mais pour tenir il faut toujours
discuter avant quand on discute pas
avant c'est valable pour un maire qui
changea sens interdit comme pour un
président qui fait une réforme des
retraites si on discute pas avant on est
sûr que la nouveauté passe mal on va
écouter pierre laurent le secrétaire
national du parti communiste français
qui étaient tout à l'heure sur la
manifestation parisienne et et lui alors
lui il y voit un élargissement du
mouvement social ce qui semble être la
marque de cette journée c'est l'entrée
dans le mouvement
deux syndicalistes de plus en plus
divers venus de nombreuses
confédérations syndicales donc
manifestement il ya des possibilités
d'élargir ce front social et c'est tant
mieux
et il faut que nous l'accompagnons est
effectivement par une mobilisation
politique important pour vous il prend
ses désirs pour des réalités
d'abord le parti même s'il y avait
décidé d'aider des adhérents de fo et la
cfdt n'a encore nommé d'ailleurs il ya
d'abord un changement fondamental c'est
que les chapes deux cas le rang des plus
rouge mais bleue ce qui montre bien que
parti communiste évolue et se modernise
toutes les aires free mise à part je
pense qu'il ya naturellement des gens
qui sont opposés à cette réforme
je pense que le gouvernement et le
parlement où d'ailleurs les
parlementaires de ma famille politique
voteront ces réformes doivent tenir le
choc
vous pensez comme emmanuel macron que
les français n'aiment pas les réformes
il aime les réformes pour les autres et
pas pour eux même si vous parler par
exemple de touche 2 de faire des choses
à la sncf
tous les français sont d'accord sauf les
cheminots qui sont touchés par ces
réformes
voilà donc c'est compliqué il faut qu'il
accepte à son global du corps social
il faut que la partie de la société qui
est concerné par une forme comprennent
et considère que quelque part aussi
c'est peut-être dans son intérêt à voir
un réseau ferroviaire une société comme
sncf qui est marche mieux qu'ils aient
plus de clients qui soient moins
critiqué pour un certain nombre de
dysfonctionnements
est ce que ce n'est pas mieux pour un
cheminot que d'accepter certains des
avantages sociaux mais d'avoir un outil
de travail qui pour lui et pour les
siens était l'outil travail donne alors
le gouvernement verse 3 milliards
d'euros joue pas tous les jours à la
sncf notamment pour financer les régimes
spéciaux vous voulez vous soutenez
également levé le chef de l'état dans sa
volonté de corriger le statut vous
n'avez en charge
déjà on l'a fait déjà avec que le
gouvernement de françois fillon on a les
avis bertrand n'a bougé
la date de 2,2 de retraite des
conducteurs qui est passé de 50 à 52 ans
on a passé les retraites des autres
cheminot a aussi deux ans
supplémentaires
voilà il faut il faut l'expliquer aux le
garçon la fille qui rentre aujourd'hui
sncf d'état dans le même esprit que
celui qui est rentré après la guerre ou
dans les années 60
et c'est faisable dans l'état actuel
compte si on ne sait si on l'expliquent
s'il ya des contreparties le pressent la
république a dit par exemple qu'il
pouvait y avoir une reprise de la bête
du système ferroviaire pour lui
permettre de se moderniser de s'agrandir
de servir au mieux ses clients enfin bon
deal c'est un deal qui mérite en tout
cas dé discuter je sais masri corps
social le corps social l'acceptera et je
pense que ce deal mérite des muscles me
sens vraiment privilégié ces cheminots
genre non sont pas privilégiés s'est pas
séparé celle qu'on gagne beaucoup
d'argent si vous mettez comparaison le
salaire d'un agent sncf et de quelqu'un
qui est une fonction similaire dans une
entreprise privée salaire de la sncf est
souvent un peu plus bas d'où la
compensation par les retraites ou la
compensation parce qu'on appelle les
facilités circulation et tout ça que la
cour des comptes de remettre en cause
d'une scène depuis 20 ans 30 ans et tout
ça nous a remis sur la table je prends
cet exemple vous pourrez parler de l'air
ayant préparé les contrôleurs aériens
pourrait parler des pilotes air france
air france le nouveau président jean
marc janaillac a été capable d'instaurer
un dialogue social pour dire il ya une
nouvelle compagnie qui peut arriver
qu'ils permettent au groupe air france
de se maintenir en vie et donc ils
discutent une question un peu un peu
piquant de dominique bussereau parce que
était en charge des transports où
jacques chirac sous nicolas sarkozy vous
avez été dans la continuité
est ce que vous considérez que vous êtes
en feignant comme le dit
macron partie de ces feignants non non
pas vraiment mais je pas sûr que
l'expression qui est malheureuse d'un du
président de la république cet été
vraiment à attribuer aux anciens
présidents
alors quand on invite anne hidalgo
valérie pécresse à l'elysée pour fêter
la victoire de la france pour les jeux
olympiques on n'invite pas les feignants
donc si il a invité ces gens là c'est
qu'ils considéraient que c'était des
gens de qualité
alors je parle de sarko dolan dont ceux
qui étaient invités alors vous dites que
le président macron a été élu sur son
programme de réformes donc il doit tenir
ce que vous avez expliqué pourtant il ya
un débat et on l'a encore entendu
aujourd'hui dans les cortèges élections
ne veut pas dire blanc seing et il ya
cette question ce procès même en
illégitimité qui est notamment fait par
jean luc mélenchon qu'est-ce que vous
emportez ce que ça vous inquiète
ce que ce que je pense si vous voulez
c'est qu'il ya eu un premier tour où le
nail macron a fait un score inférieur
d'un cent pour cent et au deuxième tour
naturellement tous les français qui ne
voulait pas entendre parler du front
national ont voté pour lui moi le
bouquet est vraiment hésité une seconde
pour hésiter le début du commencement
d'une seconde
voilà donc donc ça veut dire en effet
qu'il a été porté par une partie des
français qu une très forte abstention et
pas par la totalité des français c'est
pas les scores que faisait le général de
gaulle ou président galerie les autres
radars mais il est légitime donc dont et
bien sûr qu'il est légitime mais c'est
plus difficile pour lui parce que
d'abord il est parti d'un score de
premier tour relativement faible
deuxièmement il a une majorité
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale en
tout cas assez inexpérimentée dont
beaucoup de députés eux mêmes ne sont
pas encore très légitime sur leur
territoire qu'ils ne connaissent pas ils
n'étaient pas élus locaux précédemment
et donc ne connaissent pas le la réalité
du terrain où il travaille où il habite
donc tout ce monde-là doit apprendre à
mieux connaître la france et le rôle de
l'opposition républicaine
le rôle constructif le rôle de l air le
rôle de lully et cetera
ces deux c'est d'essayer de faire en
sorte que sur certains sujets nous
puissions trouver les accords et puis
peut-être remplacer d'une expérience de
certains par notre expérience à nous
mais li va pas un peu fort emmanuel
macron ils lancent à la fois ci chantier
un peu d'en faire code du travail csg
formation professionnelle assurance
chômage apprentissage retraite
tous ces chantiers vont être lancées
début du quinquennat en même temps il a
des mots aussi très dur quand il
s'adresse des poids aux français un peu
malheureux par moments vous l'avait dit
et ce qui a pas un problème de juste de
communication de pédagogie le temps que
le temps politique est très long prendre
un exemple on a inauguré début juillet
la ligne à grande vitesse tours-bordeaux
nous l'avions décidé que jean pierre
raffarin et jacques chirac en 2003 les
quatorze ans après on inaugure le temps
politique est très long donc si en début
de quinquennat renonce pas les réformes
connaissant le temps parlementaire qui
est très long les navettes entre
l'assemblée et le sénat
les vacances tous les évènements qui
marquent la vie de notre pays
et puis la reprise de la campagne
électorale influents des reprises
incessantes de campagne électorale qui
se déroule même s'il fait pas de bruit
l intéresse beaucoup de français c'est
celle du sénat on en parlera si nous
laissions fait passer en début de
quinquennat sont lance pas tout et bien
après sa septième et on a vu des
président réformiste je pense à valéry
giscard d'estaing
je pense à nicolas sarkozy au bout d'un
certain temps le le le charme du départ
c'était et violée parce que les réformes
était fait on avait l'impression d'une
gestion du quotidien sauf si nicolas
sarkozy a compensé sa part sa très bonne
gestion de la crise de 2008 des suprêmes
mais il faut mieux lancée au début et
puis après laisser le temps
parlementaire le temps du dialogue avec
la société mais c'est lisible pour les
français c'est moi toujours lisible en
effet c'est pas toujours lisible et ça
c'est le rôle si votre rôle d'abord de
l'expliquer de le commenter de porter un
jugement sur ces réformes c'est le rôle
des parlementaires sur leur terrain
d'expliquer c'est le rôle des élus
locaux aussi est-ce qu'il va réussir
est-ce qu'il va réussir vous et moi je
cite encore jean luc mélenchon qui mise
sur une fin prématurée du quinquennat il
est personne
il est près des prêts il est prêt à
l'arrivée est prêt à monter en sièges
business un scénario
à l'elysée très franchement très
franchement il faut que ma qu'on
réussisse si macron échoue avec un ps je
vais faire une mauvaise rim qui est dans
les choux des républicains qui ont
besoin de se reconstruire complètement
s'il échoue là on va dans une période de
troubles politiques pour notre pays donc
il est dans l'intérêt général
et pardonnez moi j'ai dit la même chose
pour françois hollande je n'ai pas voté
pour françois hollande
je n'apprécie pas le programme du parti
socialiste en début de quinquennat quand
on est républicain au sens large du
terme faut souhaiter la réussite du
gouvernement de son pays
et puis si le gouvernement ne fonctionne
pas bien le punir aux élections les
électeurs savent très bien le faire et
est parfois très rapidement mais il faut
toujours souhaité la réussite du
gouvernement de son pays
ça vous inquiète t on de dire je ne
parviens pas à cette famille politique
cette petite musique sur l'illégitimité
pas aussi ridicule franchement je trouve
que je trouve que la manière dont les
insoumis font de la politique est
parfois assez novatrice je pense à ce
jeune député ou très brillant 4e manche
qu'elle sinon accents à la clique qui
apporte un renouveau de l'image du
politique au québec est brillant mais ma
force
à force de dire illégitime à force de
pousser des cris d'orfraie
je pense que les insomnies vont aussi
détruire le socle électoral qu'il
s'était constitué au mois de mai au
match à ça vous laisse pantois non tout
à fait non mais pas du tout mais je vais
donc vous pensez que c'est le meilleur
opposant à emmanuel macron c'est ça qui
est pour l'instant celle opposant plus
bruyant c'est l'opposant le plus bruyant
le ps se reconstruira essaye de se
reconstruire
nous on a vraiment du boulot donc les
insoumis pour l'instant se font entendre
et c'est pas sain c'est pas 5e du jour
une majorité grosso modo je qualifierais
tu social-démocrate enfin de 200 centre
gauche et et comme seul adversaire est
une extrême gauche donc il faut bien
évidemment que le centre-droit et la
droite s'exprime dans notre pays
je ne dois pas du front national dont
nous avons déjà évoqué la situation tout
à l'heure dernière question utilise en
faire leur ensuite on parlera justement
de l'avenir de l heure sur le style
présidentiel sur ce qu emmanuel macron
représente aujourd'hui sur ces trois
premiers mois de mandat en gros vous
dites quoi bon côté
j'ai vu un j'aime bien le fait qu'il
soit européen j'aime bien le retour du
drapeau européen j'ai mené autour de
l'hymne européen c'est l'europe qui a
motivé toujours mon engagement politique
j'aime bien aussi certaines nouveautés
de style de comportement je trouve
moderne qui met de la fraîcheur dans la
vie politique
j'aime moins certaines opérations un peu
comme et j'aime moins ces petites
phrases du style à l'étranger qui je
pense ne servent pas sa capacité à
convaincre les français débit a fait sa
politique merci d'utiliser une question
encore si aujourd'hui on s'est rendu
compte que plus de 1000 crs se sont fait
par les pales alors ils ont des
revendications des indemnités de
déplacement et mais est-ce que ça
reflète quand même un malaise plus
général on vous refait face notamment à
la tonalité des manifestations mais ça
reflète où la difficulté du des crs qui
sont un brin gbalé de site en site pour
les événements sociaux et surtout pour
vivre en sécurité pendant l'été ont
couvert des milliers de festivals de
manifestations dans toutes les cités
touristiques françaises
ils vont dans des casernements où il ya
parfois des poux des rats ils avaient
des indemnités qu'ils étaient au moins
ceux qui les accrocher a été difficile
on les fiscalise c'est jamais bon de
feindre l'arrêt médicale
on connait tous les mecs vous les
comprenez mais je comprends et je pense
que lise l'intérieur devrait faire un
geste à leur égard parce que c'est une
formation républicaine consentons
indique dont le pays a besoin
il faut que ces hommes et ces femmes qui
composent nos compagnies de crs soit
bien traité gérard collomb qui recevra
les syndicats leur syndicat dès demain
matin
c'est guillaume daudin de l' agence
france presse qui nous rejoint
maintenant l'épreuve de vérité avec
l'iphone
bonsoir guillaume bonsoir michel bonsoir
monsieur bussereau ou bonsoir un congrès
en décembre pour les républicains et un
congrès congrès par internet
malgré par intervalles ça sera pas
physique mais il ya des vrais candidats
eux physique et notamment un laurent
wauquiez qui est souvent désigné comme
le favori pour ce scrutin
qu'est ce que vous pensez de son
élection potentiel voire probable à la
tête des républicains pensent trois
shows je pense que laurent wauquiez est
un homme de qualité je les observe en
tant président de la région rhône alpes
où il fait du très bon travail
j'observe qu'il est favori by que selon
toute vraisemblance il sera président
des républicains à la mi décembre
j'observe enfin qu'il a un langage pour
l'instant pour séduire les militants que
je trouve pour ma part souvent excessif
pas assez européen et donc pour toutes
ces raisons s'ils l'emportent
s'il venait à l'emporter il aura
sacrément intérêt à rassembler la
famille y compris des gens comme moi qui
sont des modérés qui viennent de l'udf
qui viennent du centre du centre droit
qui sont profondément européen parce que
nous nous sentirions très mal à l'aise
dans un parti qui seraient trop
nationaliste trop conservateur sur les
valeurs sociétales et qui est serait
eurosceptiques
ça veut dire que laurent wauquiez
président des républicains vous ne
quitterez pas immédiatement le permanent
non mais vous auriez de fortes exigences
on aura de fortes exigences avec alain
juppé nous sommes réunis à à
quelques-uns autour de lui au début à la
fin du mois d'août à bordeaux nous avons
éduqué nos lignes rouges ligne rouge
c'est celle là c'est pas sens commun qui
fait la politique des républicains
les républicains viennent de l'ump qui a
été conçu par le président chirac pour
être parti pro-européen et enfin il faut
mener certes une politique libérale mais
elle doit être teinté de politique
sociale
donc nous avons indiqué d'une ligne
rouge a indiqué clairement que si ces
lignes rouges vous n'êtes être de passer
ce que je ne souhaite pas nous serions
amenés à réfléchir à faire autre chose
d'accord c'est moi je fais partie de
ceux qui ont créé l'ump avec jean pierre
raffarin avait juré avec hervé gaymard
et quelques autres l'umpc tel
rassemblement des républicains libéraux
du parti républicain démocratie libérale
des radicaux des centristes cela ils
sont déjà partis à lui d y ait des
gaullistes sur des valeurs communes
donc moi je tiens beaucoup à ce que nous
gardions cet ensemble politique cohérent
mais il appartient à laurent wauquiez
s'il est élu de conserver d'héritage et
de brader alors je vous faire écouter
l'un de ses soutiens peut-être qu'il va
pouvoir vous rassuré par ses propos sur
la thématique de rassemblements
notamment c'est eric ciotti en écoute je
suis persuadé tout cas personnellement
je le souhaite que laurent wauquiez sera
élu président des républicains il va
porter le redressement de notre famille
politique avec une équipe large
rassembler il y aura l'unité de notre
famille politique et il y aura en même
temps des idées claires et fortes des
idées de droite ods et assez c'est assez
logique dans un article droit d'avoir
une vraie droite même si ça surprend
certaines alors puisse puisse exister
avoir raison 1 c'est tout le vainqueur
de l'évent ladies and drag
cc je suis pas surpris par les idées
droite mais foudre ajoutée et du centre
voilà parce que nous avons été toujours
à partir de la droite et du centre c'est
le rassemblement de l'udf créé par
giscard et du rhdp a créé par jacques
chirac qui ont formé l'ump puis qui est
devenu à l'instigation nicolas sarkozy
l'est républicain si on n'a que la
droite est pas le centre à le centre il
va partir g
peut-être en marche ou ailleurs et sans
la droite et le centre ont gagne pas une
élection
alors le lot donc une élection
présidentielle on l'a bien vu sarkozy
2007 très belle campagne et se droitise
2012 le centre la voter hollande
donc si on repart avec que la droite est
pas le centre on est sûr de perdre dans
cette envie qu'on perde
jeudi il faut avoir la droite et le
centre dans ce rassemblement voilà la
droite et du centre que monsieur
wauquiez assure vouloir faire il a
recruté le virginie calmels c' est ce
que ça peut être pour vous une sorte de
bons signes de signes favorables on a vu
aussi ces derniers jours une déclaration
laurent wauquiez qui a d'ailleurs
peut-être surpris dans son dans son
propre camp il a dit qu'il ne
reviendrait pas sur le mariage la
l'ouverture du mariage pour les couples
homosexuels coûté valérie verticale mais
c'est la première adjointe d'alain juppé
à bordeaux à la mener la liste de la
droite et du centre aux élections
régionales dans la nouvelle région aux
nouvelles aquitaine mais dans cette
affaire allait virginie calmels
représente pas le jus piste nous avons
décidé avec l'évangile et j'ai été chef
et l'egypte et à bordeaux
mais dans cette affaire elle ne porte
pas les idées jusqu'au mail de calan qui
fait partie de notre équipe qui est un
jeune homme de grande qualité
il va pour représenter la nouvelle
génération mais n'est pas le candidat
désigné porté par alain juppé donc les
jus pis nous voterons notre âme et
conscience pour les uns pour les autres
mais en tout cas personne ne peut porter
pardonnez-moi le morceau de la vraie
croix votre candidat alain juppé
candidat le candidat que j'ai parrainé
oui que oui moi je pars ml de canon
d'accord parce que j'ai plus de 60 ans
et que je pense à le lead et de donner à
des gens qui ont entre 30 et 40 ans qui
sont des valeurs montantes des
responsabilités politiques comme ça
existe en allemagne le nouveau président
du fdp qui qui aborde les élections
dimanche en république fédérale
d'allemagne comme le présent la
république lui-même est plus une bonne
idée mais mon choix de miles de calan
n'est pas un choix d'hostilité à laurent
wauquiez c'est une préférence
personnelle que avec jean pierre
raffarin quelques autres nous avons
besoin et je reviens un instant sur les
déclarations de laurent wauquiez sur
l'ouverture du mariage aux couples
homosexuels
est ce que vous trouvez que c'est un bon
signe justement qu'il se dise prête un
jeu pas revenir sur ça j'ai trouvé que
dans toute cette affaire de mariage pour
tous la droite avait été assez un garde
moi je refusais de participer à toute
manifestation
à tout événement quoi que ce soit la
matière j'ai la conviction personnelle
de chrétiens d'hommes je ne suis pas une
société ouverte et moderne
voilà donc que dès que des esprits qui
ont été un moment un peu fermé évolué ne
montre qu'une bonne chose mais par
exemple on parle aujourd'hui d'un débat
sur la pma la proc
si on également médicalement assistée
pour toutes les femmes je maman
célibataire et lesbiennes là vous dites
aussi oui effectivement il faut se
montrer ouvert et je crois que la
secrétaire d'état chargée du droit des
femmes à la charia mais n'a pas été très
maladroite d'annoncer ça d'ailleurs elle
a été reprise par gérard collomb par
d'autres membres du gouvernement
si on veut faire évoluer la société il
faut le faire là encore dans le dialogue
et la conviction vous vous n'êtes pas
fermé sur cette extension de la fin à
toutes les femmes plus de distinguer
mais sur ses déclarations
mais je pense que la manière dont ça a
été annoncé un peu maladroitement était
une erreur d'un ministre débutants qui
n'a pas rendu service et sa cause en le
faisant ainsi vous vous êtes c'est votre
cause l'endosser cette cause c'est pas
ma cause mais je suis prêt à l'accepter
au nom d' évolution de notre société
alors vous avez dit que laurent wauquiez
était favori pour cette élection oui
en face on a parlé de certains candidats
comme elle de calan il y en a plusieurs
jouets seront choisies elles ferrand
sportunit voilà un autre qui manquent
il manque certains éléphants dans la
pièce alors peut-être que quand il est
pas terrible pour les pour les
républicains parce qu'on vous alliez ne
pas risquer valérie pécresse aurait pu
légitimement être candidat et pourtant
ils ne le sont pas est ce que vous le
regrettez non parce que je pense qu'ils
ont raison de se consacrer à leur région
il faut bien voir comment xavier
bertrand est élu il a été élu sans la
gauche au deuxième tour contre le front
national
valérie pécresse a remporté une très
belle victoire dans des conditions
différentes sont à la tête des normes
région valérie pécresse en plus reçoit
cadeau d'arrivée
la tête de la région avec les géo en
france en 2024 et vouloir à la fois
diriger une région et président d'un
parti s'occuper des investitures nommer
les gens les recevoir et cetera se
balader dans les départements c'est tout
à fait incompatible donc je crois qu'ils
ont raison de dire je me consacre à ma
région je ne sais pas ça les
discréditent pas pour l'étape d'après
pour 2022 et regardez regardez regardez
ce que sont devenus les chefs de partis
ou les assimiler chefs de partis dans la
présidentielle
le fait de chef de parti a plutôt été
pour certains une croix à porter qu'un
avantage regardé nicolas sarkozy qui
pensait apparaître président et les
républicains ne gagner haut la main il a
été il a fait un score tout à fait
mauvais par rapport à ses qualités
personnelles parce que l'image de chef
de parti dans notre pays n'est pas
forcément une bonne image pour devenir
chef de dans cette élection il manque
peut-être un représentant de poids pour
les idées vous défendez vous sentez
république coûtait
quelqu'un qui aurait pu rallier sur son
nom j'ai fait tellement c'est être mais
cette personne
cette personne ne s'est pas présenté
elle se présente pas aux suffrages dans
ce difficile de chrétiens rire voilà
donc nourrir mais moi je ne critique pas
je dis invoquée si tu deviens notre
président soit le président tout le
monde si tu deviens notre président
était le président des militants les
plus les plus à droite
c'est normal dans tout parti au ps sont
les militants les plus à gauche qui sont
les militants du ps doubs benoît hamon
sort aux primaires est chez nous c'est
les militants les plus à droite d'où
alain juppé ne n'est pas au deuxième
tour des prix a fait au deuxième tour
des primaires n'est pas l'élection
présidentielle voilà donc jeudi où il
est capable de rassembler et à ce moment
là notre famille politique peut survivre
sinon après les coups que nous avons
pris en quarts dans l'élection
présidentielle étant favori après une
première de la droite et du centre
réussi les coups que nous avons pour les
hisser tirant dans notre groupe
parlementaire je j'arrive de ces
journées / les verts par les neutres ou
ne seront jamais ne seront jamais
guéries
oui donc absolument changer complètement
de logiciel wii et d'où mon choix mal de
calan personnel changer de génération
vous arrivez de 3 donc voilà nanti à 3
aux journées parlementaires des
républicains si je me trompe à fin juin
vous aviez dit que si vous aviez été élu
à l'assemblée nationale vous aurez pull
siéger avec les constructif alors
comment vous placez vous justement dans
ce débat au sein des républicains entrée
nous sauver homologue au sénat même
somme au sénat le studio public sénat où
le président du sénat une très jolie
formule cette semaine je suis ni
destructif dé constructif
ben moi je suis comme larcher comme
gérard larcher nous destructif ni
constructif je trouve où je dis que
génial je dis qu'il ya des choses bien
dans ce que fait plaisant à publica des
choses avec lesquelles je ne suis pas
d'accord on y reviendra quand on parlera
tout à l'heure peut-être des
collectivités territoriales mais je ne
veux être ni dans une opposition
systématique n'est être à béni oui oui
enfin laisse pas beaucoup d'espacé
l'espère avec l espace si vous voulez je
ne suis pas parlementaire non je n'ai
pas voté pour ou contre je suis présente
département je fais de la politique
locale et de la gestion plus que de la
politique politicienne
je crois que les gens de bonne volonté
doivent observer ce que fait le
gouvernement
la droite doit se reconstruire sur ses
idées avec le centre il faut voir ce que
va devenir en marche qui pour l'instant
est est un machin au sens onusien du
terme
et puis dans un ou deux ans trois ans la
vie politique française va se
reconstruit pour l'instant les
déconstruite lé construisait de grande
force d'alternance le psc et la droite
et le centre sont cassés donc il faut
que tout ce monde se reconstruise et on
verra bien les forces on verra les
tannants on verra la réussite des
politiques on verra les projets des uns
des autres et la vie politique française
seront construira quand viendra le temps
des élections présidentielle et des
élections législatives
laurent wauquiez président des
républicains s'il est président des
républicains est ce qu'on ne va pas
aboutir à la formation d'un grand parti
du centre inévitable je le répète si
laurent wauquiez franchi les lignes
rouges que nous avons un certain nombre
d'entre nous en particulier ceux qui
sont autour d'alain juppé menacé m'en
fixer le risque existe pour lui en effet
que se crée un parti sans tenez je lui
je le souhaite pas pour l'instant parce
que je lui ai expliqué que j'avais
contribué à la formation de l'ump qui
était le rassemblement de la droite et
du centre
démolir en 2017 ce que nous avons
commencé à faire à partir de 2000 2001
et qui s'est traduit par la création
l'ump en 2002 ça sera pas payée pour
hacker vraiment pas de gaieté de coeur
et emmanuel macron à sa manière avec les
constructif avec edouard philippe au
gouvernement ou à matignon
ils mangent déjà sur l'espace de la
droite donc est ce que ce grand parti de
la droite et du centre dont vous rêvez
est-ce qu'il a encore une éventuelle
capacité à pouvoir concurrencer coûté je
vous le dirai dans quelques mois
honnêtement on s'est tellement planté
vous et nous les politiques dans les
pronostics de la primaire de la droite
et du centre de la primaire de la gauche
de la présidentielle et des législatives
que j'ai pas trop envie de ridiculiser
sur votre antenne pour que michel
grossiord dans quelques mois mais des
alors vous aviez dit ça on voit vrai
bien que nous aviez une grosse bêtise il
est capable de me lire ils auraient
raison donc j'évite pour l'instant de
dire de grosses bêtises comme si c'était
mon genre non merci
guillaume la suite mais payant de
l'épreuve de vérité avec michael ms de
public sénat on va parler des finances
le cadre notamment des départements
[Musique]
sur michael bond saint michel bonsoir
monsieur bussereau bonsoir avec les
amazones et à trois jours des élections
sénatoriales
est ce que vous estimez aujourd'hui que
la grogne des élus locaux est en passe
de se calmer notre grâce notamment à
l'action du premier ministre
c'est françois baroin ce matin 3
participions un débat avec philippe
richert tu présent des régions une jolie
formule nous au départ il ya eu la
confiance il n'y a pas encore la
méfiance mais il ya un peu de défiance
voilà je crois que ça résume joliment la
situation pourquoi je vous dis cela
parce que le président a fait la
conférence de territoire c'est une bonne
politique ce que nous voulions ça s'est
passé ici au sénat avec le concours du
président du sénat et deux de tous les
sénateurs et qui étaient ici il y a eu
un mauvais coup pendant l'été quelques
choix après la conférence ont fait les
poches les collectivités pour 300
millions d'euros
ça c'était très maladroits les contrats
aidés on peut être pour ou contre
en tout cas si on décide de les
supprimer ou de réduire on le fait pas
quelques jours de la ruhr ont brillé les
mots de françois barois killer pas hier
devant les élus locaux été meurtrier
bah tout et c'est un joli titre de film
un très beau film ne rend précieux quand
nous étions plus jeunes
ça n'a pas été un bon été pour les
collectivités locales pour la relation
entre l'exécutif et les collectivités
locales
donc maintenant c'est l'automne le ton
commence c'est même l'été indien
aujourd'hui en france essayons de faire
que les choses partent dans une
meilleure direction il ya eu des loupés
dans le mois qui vient de s'écouler bon
parce qu'on a du mal à comprendre
oui ou non plus grave alors si vous ne
prévoyez pas comprendre parce que quand
on écoute quand on écoute mes premiers
ministres edouard philippe
il est fière a vraiment sur les finances
sur les employés à une idée très
rassurant on l'écouté edouard philippe
prévoyons nous pour le projet de loi de
finances 2010 8 et bien après trois ans
de baisse nette de la dotation globale
de fonctionnement de l'ordre de 9,3
milliards d'euros
les concours financiers aux
collectivités territoriales ne
baisseront pas en 2018 comme ça je vais
le redire
c'est comme ça ce sera clair
les concours financiers aux
collectivités territoriales baisseront
pas en 2018 ils seront même si on les
prend tous ensemble en hausse globale de
près de 384 millions d'euros ce qui sur
l'ensemble est assez peu ils ne
baisseront pas alors l'explication levé
vous et applaudi ces explications le
président la république ici au sénat la
conférence de territoire annonce 13
milliards en moins pour le bloc local
dans les cinq ans à venir
le premier ministre dit pas 2018 ça veut
dire que les 13 milliards ils pourront
éventuellement se faire entre 2019 et la
fin du quinquennat ce que propose le
gouvernement ce que vise l'intérieur et
le ministre des comptes publics que
gérald darmanin vont proposer demain aux
élus d'un système contractuel c'est à
dire pour 300 membres à 10 320 françois
barois entendu le chiffre de 350
pourrait 150 collectivités
c'est à dire toutes les régions tous les
départements mais gros agglo et quelques
grandes villes un système où en 2019 en
2018 pardon il n'y a pas de baisse des
concours et à partir de 2019 on commence
à compter des blues comme à la fin de la
foire et on regarde ce que les bons
élèves les mauvais élèves etc
mais pour que nous acceptions cela nous
les départements faut-il encore que on
sache qu'il ya dans ces contrats et par
exemple est ce que au moment de signer
ces contrats avec notre préfet de région
préfet du département
nous aurons réglé le gouvernement
d'autres dossiers parmi les plus
difficiles avec celui des mineurs
accompagnés non accompagnés se dire du
financement du rsa pas seulement admirer
sa de l'apa pour les personnes âgées qui
dans certains départements encore plus
coûteux le rsa et la prestation qu'en
passant du handicap car si j'allais
signer demain un contre avec mon préfet
pas c'est parfait pour l'année 2019 mais
qu'en même temps l'état continue de ne
pas nous payer ce qu'il nous doit sur le
financement de ces dérives sociales
vous signez pas vraiment quoi je ne
signerai pas aimer mais le canada ne
signez pas qu'est-ce qui les collectent
les un département ne signerons pas nous
allons le dire demain très
officiellement au gouvernement
non pas que nous trouvions la méthode à
contractualisation mauvaise mais parce
que nous voulons savoir quel est le
contenu du contrat et quelles seront la
réalité de nos dépenses de
fonctionnement en 2018
si l'histoire des mineurs étrangers dans
la compagne et qui va coûter au bloc
départementale 1 milliard d'euros cette
année
si la sphère du rsa et du de l'apa ne
sont pas commencés à être arrivé si la
négociation réelle et concrète n'a pas
commencé on va pas signer des contrats
dont on ne connaît pas les les clauses
et le contenu alors si on compromet
c'est à dire que vous proposez au
gouvernement aujourd'hui rsa les mineurs
isolés
vous prenez en charge on signe le
président de la république quand il a
reçu l'adf commune a reçu tous les corps
sociaux français après son élection nous
a dit très clairement les mineurs
étrangers isolés
c'est un drame souhaité français d
accueil mal c'est pas vous les
départements de gérer ça dans le cadre
de l'aide sociale à l'enfance avec les
enfants des familles un défi mortel car
c'est à l'état de river donc qu'à des
négociations qui ont commencé il ya eu
quelques avancées du tout venant du
garde des sceaux et de la ministre de la
santé mais avant c'est à nos yeux
insuffisante donc il faut qu'on avance
sur ce dossier qui devient très lourd et
très pénible
humainement dans beaucoup de
départements et financièrement de
surcroît et puis il faut qu'on trouve
une solution à ce problème de la
solidarité pour les plus pauvres et les
plus âgés de société et que si en avant
dans ces directions
naturellement nous irons dans la
contractualisation il ya quand même un
n'avance pas peut pas rentrer dans une
contractualisation dont on ne connaît
pas les termes financiers réels sur le
terrain il ya quand même un secteur où
ça va mieux c'est le rsa grâce à ces
graves ou à l'amélioration de la
conduite excessive de l'économie et
salaise moins sur les départs musan
aussi leur connaissait pas totalement
par des mois le rsa a globalement la
charge du reste a un peu diminué
oui il fait de la baisse du chômage mais
malheureusement certains présents
département me disent actuellement que
en cette rentrée avec en particulier la
fin des contrats aidés sont des gens qui
n'ont pu contrats aidés qui vont
s'inscrire au rsa ils sont en train de
voir remonter
harry chiffres de demande de rsa en ce
début du mois de septembre
aujourd'hui les départements ne peuvent
plus payer le rsa dans l'état actuel des
choses c'est pas qu'on ne peut pas payer
c'est qu'on paye à la place de l'état
imaginez que vous mouiller un
appartement 1000 euros ou un studio et
que votre locataire vous dit
je vous aime beaucoup on a signé un
contrat de 1000 euros mais je vous donne
que 600 euros tous les mois
c'est ce qui arrive au département avec
le rsa n'a pas donc tout demandant
l'état de reprendre ses responsabilités
nous sommes prêts à prendre des notes
sur le terrain les politiques
d'insertion et nous le faisons je crois
bien mais il faut qu'on clarifie la
situation de la solidarité sociale c'est
ce que vous tirez demain au gouvernement
et actuel des négociations parce qu'on
imagine que ça a voulu confiant ces
négociations et quand le téléphone de ce
n'est quand même vous aimez que le
gouvernement est prêt